[Music]
in the world of tv police procedurals
longmire stands alone
the series follows a small police
department in the middle of wyoming
where dirt roads replace city concrete
and the law officers wear cowboy boots
needless to say the story of longmire is
far from ordinary
longmire is set in the fictional
abasaroka county wyoming
the series however is mostly filmed in
new mexico specifically it's shot in
santa fe
pecos los alamos and las vegas new
mexico
not to be confused with the nevada
casino town the valley's caldera around
las vegas stands in for many of the
breathtaking wyoming exteriors including
walt longmire's cabin
the las vegas plaza stands in for the
town and workplace of longmire and the
interiors are also shot in new mexico at
a place called garson studios in santa
fe
new mexico offers a 25 to 35
tax credit whereas wyoming tops out at
15
so it's no surprise that longmire shoots
down south
new mexico also has easier
transportation and more airports
the busiest airport in the whole state
of wyoming is jackson hole with only
one terminal and nine gates plus its
roads run across mountains rivers and
canyons where extreme winter weather has
been known to cause closures as late as
june
any production shot in wild places will
face challenges
when filming out west one of those
challenges can be wildfires
while filming season 2 in 2013 wildfires
surrounded the set locations
the thompson ridge fire raged on one
side of the preserve
while the trace lagoonist fire hemmed
them in from another direction
covering the sky with smoke at first
producers tried to shift locations
given the fact that the small area in
new mexico is full of firefighters and
emergency crews however producer chris
donahue said to the albuquerque journal
that they halted
everything because they quote didn't
want to be in the way of
any of the responders the arizona-based
granite mountain hotshots were part of
the team that eventually put out the
fires
unfortunately on june 30th 2013 19 of
those firefighters died fighting the
yarnell hill fire near prescott
the season 2 finale bad medicine honored
the deceased hotshots in the credits by
saying
dedicated to the granite mountain
hotshots and all the firefighters who
saved the historic buildings in the
valley's caldera national preserve
those heroic firefighters would end up
inspiring their own movie
only the brave starring josh brolin
miles teller and jeff bridges
longmire opened up with strong numbers
and its ratings grew
over the first three seasons season two
rose to about six million viewers and
season three only dropped slightly to
5.6 million viewers
and yet despite the high ratings
longmire got cancelled after just
three seasons why it was unexpected
considering the fact that season 3 ends
in a cliffhanger with a father possibly
killing his
son but there was another reason for the
cancellation
longmire's fans were too old a e said it
canceled the hit show because the
average viewer age was 60
versus the 48 year olds who made up a
e's average demographic
so apparently it took a e three seasons
to figure out that a police procedural
about a cantankerous old cowboy sheriff
who refuses to get a cell phone might
appeal to older viewers
after longmire was canceled warner
horizon the producer of longmire began
shopping it around
given the large audience there was
obviously demand especially due to the
season 3 cliffhanger
a e said that the older audience was
less appealing to advertisers but
netflix doesn't have to worry about
advertisers so it was a perfect match
for the series
netflix picked up the first three
seasons and announced it would launch
new ones
eventually netflix canceled the series 2
though the streamer's reasons are still
unknown
at least it gave the team behind
longmire the ability to finish their
series with a proper finale in season
six
jacob nighthorse is a calculating
slippery and calm villain throughout the
longmire tv series
even his rise in the tribal committee
can be traced to a murder
early on in the series yet night horse
doesn't appear in
any of the longmire books nighthorse is
the most
unpredictable and dynamic character in
the tv series
a businessman and casino owner he's
often an enemy of the absaroka sheriff's
department
and at times even an enemy of his own
tribal law enforcement
but then he'll testify on walt's behalf
or support katie longmire's effort to
become a lawyer for the tribe
the performance in the series by actor a
martinez is so compelling that his name
ended up inspiring a character in the
longmire novel
depth of winter dr ayden martinez while
the character is a great show of
appreciation to nighthorse and
a martinez this new doctor can't compare
to nitors for
impact on the series and longmire's life
there have been
many changes from the books to the
television series but this one adds
texture to the mythology of walt
longmire
absaroka county doesn't exist in wyoming
craig johnson the novelist who created
absaroka county in his longmire book
series
settled down in ucross wyoming after
years of traveling around the country
however johnson has said that the basis
for the town of durant
is buffalo wyoming and buffalo is the
seat of johnson county
so it would seem absaroka county is
based on the real johnson county but
would walt longmire stop there
no he'd look at the fact that the
wyoming counties named after mountain
ranges such as teton and uinta have part
or
all of that range in it the absaroka
mountains run just east of yellowstone
and the tetons and extend down to the
wind river range
in the episode called population 25 vic
moretti's husband
sean says they're five hours from
jackson hole the combination of the
distance from jackson as well as the
location of the range
leads to durant being near cody wyoming
or possibly thermopolis the seat of hot
springs county
on a map scene in the sheriff's office
however the location for durant
is right where the real world sheridan
is where is this absurd event
that's a mystery fit for walt longmire
himself
buffalo wyoming gets the credit for
being the real life durant because
johnson said the town's layouts and
buildings
served as inspiration while writing the
books and it makes sense given that
the town only had a county sheriff and
his team of deputies
so there's a longmire festival in
buffalo wyoming longmire days
features events inspired by the book and
tv series as well as interactions with
the cast and crew
some of the highlights include talks
with robert taylor and craig johnson
a horseback ride with some of the actors
a softball game and
an auction there's even a chance to grab
a drink at the red pony and in the past
they've had events like a talk from the
two henrys in the show
that event happened during the longmire
days festival when the organizers held a
talk with lou diamond phillips who plays
henry in the series
it is a beautiful day at the red pony
and continual soiree this is henry
robert taylor who plays sheriff walt
longmire is an australian actor who
excels at playing an american tough
show co-creator john coveny said in an
interview with assignment x that
their character combination for walt was
harrison ford clint eastwood
and steve mcqueen coveny went on to
explain that they found that all in
robert taylor
for his part taylor said to front row
features the role needed a
quote quietness of soulfulness that
isn't often seen anymore he added
you would see it in actors like gary
cooper and clint eastwood but i didn't
base my character on any of those guys
while robert taylor may not have
purposely channeled personality traits
from all those legendary cinematic
actors
they seem to fit him like a pair of
well-broken in cowboy boots
robert taylor has been kicking around
hollywood for years but his most popular
and
longest running role is playing sheriff
walt longmire
however the role of walt longmire almost
went to coach taylor or
more specifically the actor who played
him kyle chandler
chandler's turn as the coach on the nbc
show friday night lights brought him a
lot of industry buzz
he went on to other roles in many
acclaimed movies such as argo
zerodark 30 the wolf of wall street and
manchester by the sea
while chandler's early career included a
country movie the actor himself is a bit
of a joker and might have brought some
of the levity to the series that
longmire carries through the book series
as he's matured chandler has also
adopted a bit of the roguish tough
cowboy look that would have fit the
sheriff we all know
executive producer hunt baldwin grew up
in chicago and worked in advertising for
many years
his parents moved to wyoming and that
bold move inspired him to eventually
leave his safe existence
and move to los angeles to become a
full-time writer there he worked hard
for many years before eventually
fulfilling his dream
working with his writing partner john
covny on their series the closer
baldwin and company are both represented
by the same agent at talent agency caa
and it was that shared connection at caa
that gave rise to longmire
according to company they had talked to
their agent over the years about wanting
to do a modern western
company mentioned that he had been a big
fan of butch cassidy and the sundance
kid
their agent then mentioned that caa also
happened to be representing an author
named craig johnson who'd written a
series of modern day western centering
on a cowboy sheriff
according to company they read the cold
dish and said
about 10 pages in we knew it was
something we wanted to develop
baldwin and coveney's experience working
together on lapd police procedural the
closer was a big help when they began
developing longmire
they still needed an executive producer
with experience running a show though
luckily while at the closer they met and
worked closely with producer greer
shepard
so they set up a meeting with her to
discuss this new project
greer is a tv veteran she produced her
first series in 1997
nothing sacred one of her first big hits
as an executive producer was nip tuck in
2003
she was the perfect person to shepherd
two first-time creators through a
decidedly
unique police procedural according to
baldwin and companies interview with
assignment x
it took about three years from that
first sit down to longmire
eventually premiering on a e it quickly
became a relationship made in tv heaven
in fact
shepard mentioned in a 2012 interview
with the hollywood reporter that if she
could add
any writer to her staff she would quote
clone hunt baldwin and john coveny
there are many differences between craig
johnson's longmire books and
baldwin and shepard's longmire tv series
and while the book plots inspire the
storylines the series has created
many new stories in the books absaroka
county only had
5 murders in 24 years yet police
procedurals on tv tend to have
lots of murders because it makes for
very compelling television
in longmire there's a new murder almost
every episode
also in the books walt longmire's wife
isn't murdered but instead dies of
cancer
his wife's murder in the tv series is a
central plot point in the series but
one of the largest differences is
longmire himself
in the books walt longmire is witty many
would say he's riley humorous
in fact the books are often praised for
their humor but robert taylor plays
sheriff walt longmire straight
almost to a fault the only comedy we see
from tv walt longmire is when he makes
social or
technological faux pas a humor generated
from
everybody else's reactions to his
unwillingness to embrace the modern
world
in the few moments when walt says
something funny he doesn't
seem to realize it there are many
peculiarities that make longmire and its
protagonist
so memorable the fact walt doesn't have
a cell phone nor does he
ever use gloves the crime scenes are
just two but one of the most
well noted ticks is walt longmire's
devotion to rain your beer
rainier is a cheap beer that isn't found
all over comparable in price to pbr
and also owned by pabst brewing company
in an interview with the casper star
tribune
johnson explains he was surprised by how
long meyer has impacted rainier beer
johnson said i figured walt's not a
blueberry microbrew kind of guy
johnson also charges one very
inexpensive and unique item for speaking
at
any and all wyoming libraries a six-pack
of rainier
there is one more connection though the
longmire historic district in washington
is the location of mount rainier
national park
so perhaps that longmire rainier
connection may have influenced johnson
in naming his famous sheriff
there are no confirmed statements that
say walt's last name was inspired by his
favorite beer so
this might just be another mystery for
walt longmire but when it comes to tying
together supposed coincidences to suss
out the truth
there's nobody better check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one